have you ever been influenced by some of
the crazy theories your fans come up
with for mysteries in the books have you
ever changed an aspect of your story
based on fan feedback ie if one of their
theories is better than what you were
originally planned no but I am concerned
about that possibility which is one of
the reasons I don't tend to read the fan
boards I mean when the first fan board
started occurring and they started to
rising and analyzing the books in such
detail and I'm going back now to the mid
90s really when when the first boards
appeared Dragonstone coming out of
Australia that Peter gave brand I think
was the first board I was aware of and a
couple others came up after that I was
very flattered and I did read all the
theories and then precisely this point
occurred where it says you know what if
they're guessing the things that I
haven't revealed yet what if they
guessed them correctly how does that
affect me do I then say oh my god they
figured it out already I better change
it or do I just ignore it and plow ahead
and what if they come up with better
ideas than the ones I had do I steal
them and I didn't like any of these
possibilities so I said it would be
better for me to try to keep my distance
and not not go on these boards and try
to I did some well it's a futile effort
because people also write me emails and
people come to public forums like this
and and you know they come up with me at
signings and whispering theories in my
ear and things like that so I am kind of
aware of some of the speculation out
there but I keep my distance from it
precisely because I don't want to be
impacted I mean you know it's one of the
it's one of the drawbacks of the the
whole internet culture in this world
that you guys have created that
something that previously maybe one
reader in a thousand would have guessed
but you still had the other 999 it would
it have no inkling until you reveal it
in a book now that one person in a
thousand puts it on an Internet message
board and everybody sees it and they say
Oh
yeah yeah that's right no no I see the
clues I got it and pretty soon half the
readership or at least the
internet-savvy portion of your
readership knows it but what do you do
then do you change it and come up with
something goofy and outlandish that you
haven't led d you haven't done the the
foreshadowing for that you haven't laid
the foundation for just in order to
surprise people I mean sure I could have
like aliens come down and that would
certainly surprise the Hat of everybody
no one is predicting that but it would
ruin the series so so basically you
can't you can't let yourself be
influenced by this stuff is and I try
not to great